تجددت المظاهرات الرافضه للتعديلات
القضائيه في اسرائيل صباح اليوم بعد ليله
شهدت مظاهرات وصفت بالحاشده وتجمع الاف
المتظاهرين في تل ابيب ورددوا هتفه رافضه
للتعديلات القضائيه وافاد مراسل الجزيره
بان المتظاهرين اغلقوا شوارع رئيسيه عده
في المدينه
في المقابل دعا اليمين الاسرائيلي
لمظاهرات في انحاء اسرائيل دعما لاستمرار
التعديلات القضائيه كما دعا رئيسه لجنه
الدستور في الكنيسه الاسرائيلي جمهور
اليمين للنزول الى شوارع ضد وقفه تشريعات
القضائيه
في الاثناء اعلن رئيس نقابه العمال العامه
في المرافق الاقتصاديه في اسرائيل بدورها
اعلنت نقابه الاطباء الاضراب العام في
المرافق الصحيه حتى اتضح مسار التعديلات
القضائيه في اسرائيل واعلنت ايضا الجامعه
الاسرائيليه اضرابا عاما احتجاجا على
التغييرات في الجهاز القضائي واعلن رؤساء
سلطات محليه الدخول في اضراب مفتوح عن
الطعام امام ديوان رئاسه الوزراء في القدس
الغربيه اعتبارا من اليوم